c'est une conférence de presse qui aura
duré plus de 15 minutes ici au tribunal
de grande instance de paris une
conférence de presse donnée par le
procureur de la république de paris
suite à la nuit du 21 novembre
l'interpellation musclée du producteur
de musique dans son studio dans le 17e
arrondissement le producteur de musique
michel est clair suite à cette
intervention musclée quatre policiers
avaient été placés en garde à vue dans
les locaux de l'igpn énormément de
blessures deux plaies ont été révélés à
l'issue de l'examen médical du
producteur de musique le conte le
procureur de la république a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
je vous propose d'écouter le procureur
de l'inculte le placement en détention
provisoire des trois premiers policiers
a été requis en considération du trouble
exceptionnel et persistant à l'ordre
public provoqué par la gravité de
l'infraction des circonstances de sa
commission et de l'importance du
préjudice qu'elle a causés et la fin
d'éviter un risque de concertation entre
les auteurs ou de pressions sur les
témoins s'agissant du quatrième
fonctionnaires de police auteur présumé
du jet de grenade son placement sous
contrôle judiciaire a été requis avec
notamment une interdiction d'exercer ses
fonctions
dans cette affaire la justice
s'attachera à faire toute la lumière sur
ces faits dans le respect des principes
qui la gouvernent trop policiers en
détention provisoire un autre sous
contrôle judiciaire interdiction
d'exercer son métier vol à skis a été a
déclaré annoncé par le procureur de la
république à l'issue de cette conférence
de presse je vous rappelle que la sphère
éclair était même au coeur des
différentes manifestations hier sur la
loi sécurité globale cette affaire est
même monté dans les plus hautes sphères
de l'état le président de la république
ainsi que gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur ont demandé que la lumière
soit faite assez rapidement sur cette
affaire et cette interpellation musclée
du 21 novembre